yeah welcome to this video playing grant
NASA mandragora from yeah it's Thailand
here it's a good friend of mine who now
lives in known in Thailand um yeah this
is a pet line of our student okay let's
see what happens he's a very low rated
yeah I think not one I percent sure but
I think sometimes he lets his students
play on the account and he's very strong
let's play him actually normally he
would have liked to 425 one on five
minute so it's a bit unlucky to catch
him hit with very no rating I'm trying
this some line again with the pawn
sacrifice let I tried this before
without much success okay
rook c8 intending evil and 94 I don't
know I mean I really should study this
if I play it but I know the thing is I
really know him inside out we all know
each other's preferences so I thought he
formed but ok can take twice and play 95
hmm ok I want to prevent 465 is really
an annoying move and also 95 yeah what I
wanted to say i know i'm inside authors
got a good technical player and this is
maybe a bit of a surprise for him yeah I
think I'm threatening me for now takes
takes Knight moves Knight d4 and then
I'm threatening on e2 and also rope see
192 so I'm he needs to be careful now
maybe Knight c3 yeah now I could I could
play a form but he would go to e1 e2 e1
probably
d 4 is really probably not leading to
too much you for taste takes 90 194
quindi one now and then I don't really
have a move unfortunately or should I go
pick up with six assembly it looks very
slow there may be anyway at least he
cannot play we should be three or
something and I'm threatening deform
Queen a4ai go push up to to d6 now but
it's questionable if I really have
compensation here yeah I guess if I
intend to play this again I should
really study at a bit okay at least I've
got down good down good actor pieces
we take sir twice him I'm at least
active I mean you can take a seven but
I've heard deformity hoping to make use
of negative pieces if he plays Bishop f4
now I have Roxy for okay if not so i
spending lots of time okay yeah Roxy
phone does them the the normal reaction
what is got the Queen d1 and maybe I
should do that anyway come on try to to
get out of him 21 on maybe Queen B 6 or
Bishop c5 levy Bishop c5 at least I'm
active against f2 wat SI bishop
that's probably not full compensation
but it's not at all easy to to play for
white you you have some activity maybe
this compensation I don't know hmm i'm
not i'm not sure what white should do
now is playing very slowly whoo yeah
come on he doesn't have much time me to
get going here yeah thought just route
chief for rock g for maybe two to see
for even if I take it I can also tends
to stick and back to g6 now i'm
intending to go edge form okay yeah okay
once you seven that's not a bad diagonal
okay let's get hit him
and yeah 94 come on attending night h2
playing directly oldest only got 20
something seconds yeah take a 19-5 or is
the Queen g5 maybe okay I need to take
first and now Queen g5 threatening night
age too yeah right h2 now right before i
can i can also just move the Queen yeah
I just it's tricky to play I mean I
don't know it's probably not one hundred
percent correct sacrifice here but down
but it's tricky I mean look at this
position maybe he has something bad
enough but this kind of position it's
not that it's not so easy I mean here
this is probably compensation I don't
know how is white going to to get some
active play going it's not easy the
computer wants to go 92 and then night
a4 with the very slight advantage yeah
this is maybe m-maybe the way to play
it's not but for human it's not easy of
course I was mainly hiring away here
because he was a bit bigger one time and
this is very very tricky to defend with
little time yeah thanks for watching